Portnoy said that uh you know this
wasn't up to him he doesn't like it so
today we have to fire Ben Mintz he then
posted a video later addressing fans who
were calling him out as a sellout and as
someone who's participating in cancel
culture and he responded to that with
another video I think we have that yeah
we sold the out and that's what you
do when you're entrepreneurs I've never
been in the position where someone's
offered me uh you know what was it in
total almost over 400 million dollars in
total um no one's ever offered me that
kind of money for anything that I've
done and so I can imagine it's you know
quite an incentive to take the offer and
I don't blame him for taking it no I
don't that in and of itself I wouldn't
call Sally honestar but it does mean
that if you consider bar stool Sports to
be some sort of uh organization that
stands at stands against cancel culture
stands for any kind of values at all if
that's if that's the the notion you had
in your head well then that notion
should be should a long time ago but
especially now I think you should see it
better